في السياق ذاته قال اعضاء في المجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون الامنيه والعسكريه
في اسرائيل ان الجيش لم يحقق حتى الان ايا
من اهداف الحرب في قطاع غزه واضاف
المسؤولون في تصريحات نقلتها صحيفتها
اريتس ان قدرات حركه حماس العسكريه
والمدنيه ما تزال قائمه وتؤدي وظائفها وان
قادتها العسكريين احياء كما ان غالبيه
الانفاق لم تهدم بعد وبخصوص الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في قطاع غزه الذين يحتجز في
غزه بعد السابع من اكتوبر قال المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون ان نصف الاسرى الاسرائيليين
ما يزالون في يد الحركه وقال الاعضاء انه
وبعد ثلاثه اشهر من الحرب لا تزال حماس هي
من يسيطر على قطاع غزه وان نزع سلاح
الحركه بحاجه الى اشهر
عده مجددا اعود اليك سيد محمد اذا هذه
الاهداف التي كنت تتحدث عنها التي لم يتم
تحقيقها حت او تحقيقها حتى الان برايك هل
ستبدد الخلافات
وتعيد اعاده الالتفاف حول هذه الاهداف في
الداخل
الاسرائيلي
اي ابدا اي وجود هذه الخ الاهداف واستعصى
على التحقق هو ذاته الذي سيفجر المشهد
وسيستمر في تصاع في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي تذكرين مع بدايه هذه الحرب
اعلن نتنياهو وكابينه الحرب هذه الاهداف
الكبيره وضخ في المجتمع الاسرائيلي الامال
بامكانيه تحقيقها الان بعد مرور ثلاثه
اشهر على هذه الحرب المجنونه التي تخاض ضد
القطاع لم يتحقق انهاء حكم حماس وسيطرتها
ولم يتحقق عوده الاسرى ولم يتحقق ردع ومنع
حماس من استمرار تهديد اسرائيل واطلاق
الصواريخ كما تفضلتم بالاشاره في مطلع هذه
المداخله اذا المجتمع الاسرائيلي التفويض
الذي يمنحه لهذه الحكومه والذي منحه لهذه
الحكومه منذ بدايه هذه المواجهه كان بشكل
او باخر بشكل ضمني مشروط بان تتحقق هذه
الاهداف بالاضافه الى وجود حكومه قادره
على تشكيلها متماسكه متضامنه اليوم يظهر
جليا للمجتمع الا الاسرائيلي ان الحكومه
فقدت يعني قدرتها على تحقيق هذه الاهداف
وهذه الا الاهداف تتمنع وبالتالي يزداد و
تزداد القناعه داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بانه لحكومه قادره على تحقيق هذه الاهداف
مع هذه الخلافات التي تطفو على السطح كيف
لحكومه تتسارع اركانها الاساسيه في كابنه
الحرب وتطفو خلافاتها على السطح ان تحقق
اهدافا بعيده المنال الحد الادنى هو عوده
الاسرى لم يتحقق ونتنياهو ما زال يضخ
الاكاذيب والتضليل في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ان الذهاب الى الحرب البريه هو
الذي او الكفيل باعاده هؤلاء الاسرى في
حين ان الاشارات التي ترد يوميا ان مزيد
من الاسرى يقعون ضحايا وحتى ضحايا النار
الاسرائيليه وبالتالي نعم هنالك تعزز لهذه
القناعه ليس فقط على مستوى قواعد شعبيه
انما على مستوى نخب عسكريه كان لها
تجربتها الطويله في ميدان العمل السياسي
والعسكري رؤساء اركان رؤساء وزراء سابقون
كتاب كلهم بات يدرك بان هذه الحرب لا تذهب
لاعتبارات تحقيق هذه الهداف التي اشرنا
اليها انما الاعتبارات استمرار نتنياهو في
الحكم واستمرار ائتلافه في الحكم لذلك
هذا هذه الخلافات التي باتت اكثر حده في
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي تعبر عن مخاوف
المجتمع الاسرائيلي الحقيقيه من ان هذه
الاهداف لن تتحقق واكثر من ذلك الان
نتنياهو يذهب الى مغامرات جديده يخرج فيها
عن سياق الحرب الداخليه في غزه الى تفجير
المشهد في الاقليم لتحقيق اعتبارات بقاء
ائتلافه في داخل الحكم وهروبه من المسائله
والمحاسبه